thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing and special episode of off the
Record Joe take it away so in another
video that we had to cut off prematurely
[Laughter]
I I was inspired to ask you this
question because you kind of like danced
around the topic of dating yeah yeah and
then you mentioned that dudes want a
bone but they don't want to stay in a
committed relationship with you or maybe
they're not interested in doing those
things with you how has that been as
like I don't know ever since you started
uh only fans or has it always been like
that before see I say this every time
someone asks me this question
no one ever wanted to date me anyways
so before before only no really no men I
I think it's actually funny because I am
most confident about my personality and
I'm like most insecure about my looks
but for guys they always want to [__] me
for my looks and then they get to know
me and they're like oh God
I just wish so it's the opposite yeah so
they hit your personality
um they well I they always tell me I'm
like a frat boy and I get that but it's
like they don't want to date a frat
brother so what that just blows my mind
because a lot of guys a lot of guys do
like tomboys yeah I don't I want to say
I'm a tomboy but it's like my part very
feminine looking thank you my heart is a
tomboy yeah I get along with guys a lot
better I can't deal with anyone who's
jealous like if you're even slightly
jealous like a lot of my best friends
are guys it's like you have to get wait
let me first do some detective diving so
we have context what is your type of guy
oh God because maybe you're not matching
with the type of guys because I'm like
the guys you're describing there's a lot
out there
my type is tall skinny it kind of like
looks like you might do meth kind of
like a like a machine gun Kelly yeah
yeah except like I wouldn't get along
with his personality that well
um I think he tries very hard yeah
because the guys are paying him like I
already sounds like a [__] boy dude
isn't that what you're saying too though
like maybe they maybe they visually want
your type but wouldn't get along with
your personality yeah some
but it's like I've gone for
gone for really fun welcoming quirky
like if they can dance like really
really bad for some reason that's a turn
on to me or even like dance
[Music]
that's not you definitely not these guys
you just like the the want to want to
embarrass yourself but without feeling
embarrassed like I do that [__] all the
time and I don't I should get
embarrassed but I don't but it's like
I'm looking for that quality in a person
yeah they just don't give a [__] yeah
that's cool um so that's that's what I'm
looking for but I'm not like actively
looking I'm not really like I mean I
like swipe on Tinder sometimes just to
get people to want to subscribe to me
but um it's it's marketing to me before
yeah yeah when I was on Tinder
yeah and then we actually became friends
on Instagram
for only 199 a month
because I've had more men interested in
dating me after I created on only fans
than before but I've noticed there's
some aspect of the men who want to date
me are really poor and they want me to
pay for things oh I mean well so they
want a sugar mama yeah one of them one
of the guys the one who I was like oh my
God I wanted to throw up after [__]
him
um why because he was broke no no no
there there were two things where I was
just the support that's what they called
the ick yeah I got the X uh he was
saying something we were [__] and he
said like darling and I was like darling
was he a vampire
like what
what darling and then the second thing
is he's like I know you like to [__]
fast because it's like I love dubstep
[__] me to 140 BPM or I don't want to
[__] you yeah that's a tough Pace to
keep yeah so people can't keep that pace
yeah Cotton Eye Joe's a pretty fast song
wait he was like I know you like to [__]
fast but let's just slow it down for a
second and I was like and for something
about that made me I was like he wanted
to romance you yeah I'm like I don't
want that slow sensual [__] he's like
let's just and I was like I felt my
vagina drying up and I was like I just
want to go to bed I just want to go to
bed I was like
uh and I tried so hard to like him I
tried so hard no but he also made a
comment like the next day about being
like a stay-at-home husband or something
like that and I was like throw up even
more drop even more I think it is
you need to date older dudes because
these gen z boys are too feminine that's
exactly what I was thinking
it's gen Z
because he was a millennial oh yeah
because like I think there's a ton of
dudes in our generation yeah that fit
what you're looking for yeah and then
I'm like when when you're describing
what you're talking about it sounds like
soft ass dudes
what the [__] yeah so I'm like a few
days
I'm down
he's Millennial so they're still young
enough late 30s early 40s Millennial
right so they're like the first gen
first gen Millennial not the later gen
right x-con but he changed his life yeah
yeah so he's hard like he's been around
right right X gone because because you
like the Smugglers right you like the
guys
it's so fun I've been on a lot of dates
actually where guys will try to like I
don't I only drink like once a month now
but like I went to University of Arizona
like I was pounding shots and guys will
try to keep up with me drinking wise on
dates all of a sudden one guy after a
day passed out on my kitchen floor after
I told him to leave in the fetal
position try to kick him awake didn't
wake up for like an hour or two it's
like guys cannot keep up with me they
have to be secure enough in their
masculinity that I will out drink them
and I will do more drugs than them
shrooms but still I will do both way
more than them yeah you need to find a
Cocaine Cowboys yeah see I don't like
people who do a lot of coke I don't want
you doing cocktails four or five in the
morning
because a former guy he would relate
with you he would understand all the
stories he would do all like a reformed
dude exactly he used to do a lot of coke
he used to do a lot of coke now it's
just shroom fungus friends yeah
different drugs are those guys now you
do drugs for Spiritual reasons
I love that kind of day yeah okay or if
you don't like that you need a special
ops dude that's trying to find him
he's been through the crazy [__] but
then he can tolerate all the stories and
he doesn't feel like a a a little girl
around you gotta go to
our treats yeah
with a couple as a couple you're not
supposed to do it because um I actually
know this guy he's a photographer in the
only Fan's business but he has he's
known for taking girls right when they
start dating on an Ayahuasca trip an
emotionally manipulates them and
basically like oh [__] yeah it's really
like you can emotionally
people on Ayahuasca so if you were so
connected yeah I hate you I literally
hate you I think you scared of me though
stop actually if you think about it yeah
no it's no and then and then people will
know who I'm talking about but um just
not gonna say his name so I don't get
sued but he then convinces the girl to
move in the middle of nowhere where she
has no friends and then it's just them
too and then he like checks her phone
doesn't let her hang out with anybody
isolates her and then he tries to act
like he's the victim and it's like they
can be known for yeah yeah he's like
known for that and it's like it's just
so CR I hate him so much because I'm
very protective of my girlfriends and it
happened to one of them oh God that's
like some cult [__] yeah yeah why can't
they just have a normal relationship you
know like you know you love each other
why is that so difficult to do I don't
know no Ayahuasca day one I know it was
like literally like two weeks after they
started dating dude and then just pray
on the vulnerabilities that come out
yeah
but I'm lucky that I have a very hard
exterior because I notice a lot of men
who are either like narcissists or
creepy or any they're very scared of me
but I love that power if you're gonna
because you're gonna call out their [__]
yeah yeah
like I at subtronics like what was it
two or three weeks ago there was this
guy who came up to me a little short man
he was like
I need I need to demasculate him a
little bit he's like I really want to
make my ex-girlfriend jealous can I kiss
you for a picture and I said no and he
kept pestering me thinking I was gonna
change my mind and then it's a wild
request that's [__] weird this guy's
cool can you bring him on this guy's
chill you don't need a demasculine like
he already did it the weirdest thing I
or anything I shoved him and I was like
get out of here you physically shoved
yeah it physically shocked him yeah and
then was he like 90 pounds so if he
tumbled and then he went up to him he
went up to my one friend basically lied
to her being like I don't understand I
was just trying to be nicer and she
hates me so then he tried to have her
talk to me for him and then I pushed him
again it took three times pushing him oh
little man
yeah yeah f word gaffit yeah no we don't
say slurs here and like well not unless
I've never heard that before
that's why I'm telling you these younger
dudes are they're weird they're weak I
don't need a man to protect me I will
scare the [__] out of you on my own even
though how tall was he he he was
probably like five five yes but here's
the thing shorter than me garbage I'm
five six and I'm like dude you're a tiny
little boy we're so close to a site
we're like [__] that guy yeah he's a
piece of [__] I can put you in my pocket
when's the last time you actually had a
relationship relationship like a real
one five six guys hate him
it's like years and years and years was
it pre-only fair today's video is
brought to you by Warby Parker baby
Warby Parker office everything that you
need for happier eyes you see this it's
going hahaha cause I got Warby Parker
eyeglasses sunglasses contact lenses and
even eye exams my friend and you could
shop with them online or in stores too
because I've seen them all over the
place now look everything you need to
know about your new pair they have
booklets to explain like a religion yep
glasses start at 95 including
prescription lenses try Warby Parker's
free home try on program get five pairs
of glass of crown at home for free like
this there is no obligation to buy ships
free and also includes a prepaid return
shipping label so what I like about this
is you know sometimes you're buying
things online you're like man you get
the computer monitor and you go like
this in the mirror and try to see if it
looks good but you can't tell if it
looks good right right no you're like I
wish someone would send me five glasses
for free that's what I say specifically
someone sent me five glasses for free
and also come with a prepaid return
shipping label good thing Warby Parker
does that wow answers all of oh my
goodness exactly that you take a quick
little quiz like what we did and then we
chose five glasses and here they are I
kind of like what they look like if
you're like me and you want to be
efficient you don't buy just one thing
at a time you buy a bunch of them and
what's cool is they're all free so you
don't have to have any money out of
pocket and you only pay for the one that
you actually want but you get to save
time because you can narrow down which
ones I
like this
I and maybe I'd like it I'm not sure but
then you get to try for a little bit and
it's not like you have to make the
decision like you're at the store and
you're like oh is this gonna get me a
date I don't know or is this one gonna
get me a date I don't know and then you
gotta choose like five minutes and then
you're out the store but this one is in
your own home so you can put on
different outfits you could be like you
know in the you could be in the rearview
mirror in the car and you could be like
in your own bathroom anywhere right you
could just like check you could be
cooking some steak you check yourself
out in the kitchen in the reflection
like yeah this is [__] good yeah you
could test drive them you know what I
mean just like sometimes you wish you
could test drive your wife but you can't
yep so try five pairs of glasses at home
for free at warbyparker.com off the
Record yeah yeah and to be fair the only
reason we were like technically in a
relationship is because so like I had
lost my celibacy to this guy I say like
I lost my celibacy because it had been
over a year of not having sex and it's
like I had a crush on him for so long
and we finally were hanging out and it
took me like a week or two to actually
like [__] him but like he knew where my
head was at and then I started hearing
like oh he was with this girl he was
with that girl so then I got so drunk
you like players I yelled at him I was
like you they're just [__] me or
you're [__] no one it's either
boyfriend girlfriend or another thing
and he's like okay I guess you're my
girlfriend but he wasn't like excited oh
that's a [__] way to
so but then he entered things with me
like on what was it like not what is it
like right before finals that like last
party uh like something Wednesday and
then he's like yeah I'm [__] over
this I'm like okay but we still hooked
up for about two years after so that was
really fun is he is he is he really good
looking does does he have a lot of women
chasing him ah
I was really attracted to him all my
friends were like he looks like an ugly
little donkey
what was it about him what was it about
the what what made you go you have
honest friend that's the dude I don't
know because I had a crush on him for
like six months before I was finally
like hi I looked him up on the class
list and everything to find his
Instagram it's cute and like so it's
like when we finally started hanging out
he was like giving me so many
compliments and I felt so special to
like oh my God I had a crush on him for
so long because he's really good at like
making you feel special until he decides
like oh [__] I really want to [__] some
other [__]
I think that's just a lot of young dudes
though like we're confused between horny
and love and sometimes you Romance the
hell out of a girl and treat her like a
10 because you're just not sure if you
actually love them or not and then like
you get post-com clarity and then you're
like oh wait I just want to have a lot
of sex no see it was like two months of
him being like head over heels for me
and it was like the last month that I
just started noticing like a huge shift
and then after that he like came to like
visit me in LA and stuff like that and
like it just so many things were
different and then it was just like when
we were drunk he would tell me he loved
me so I would [__] him and then I would
and then he would like go hook up with
another girl in front of me and bring
her in front of me to like mind [__] you
know he's like hey Adelia and then I
would start like crying
how tall was he actually okay he just
wants to hate him so much he was five
nine yeah it's not even that [__] that
guy dude piece of [__] I'm 5V you're an
[__]
I [__] am
can't even see my face stand up straight
my last draw with this kid because he
like he loved the like mind games and
the mind Fox he texted me I bought a gun
and I'm gonna kill myself and I was
calling him all of his friends he's that
kind of guy too no but then he texted me
when he was sober and he's like oh I was
totally kidding I just wanted to see how
you would react it's not a joke for us
no dude that was my last straw where I
was kind of like blocked on everything I
never want to see this kid again yeah
there's so many weirdos out what the
[__] is that yo yeah but it's like he
wasn't even being serious I called all
of his friends and like he seems to be
doing fine like I don't he's like why
are you calling my friends I'm like
because why are you taking my threats
seriously
I was just kidding that you should do
yeah you know the thing I do I scare the
[__] out of everybody
it's my [__] that's not good I know I'm
working on a new one it's the first time
for you don't ruin it for everybody no
that's a big red flag
[Laughter]
so when you when you're celibate how
often do you come into the situation
where you have to tell a guy sorry
nobody
actually it's one of my oh like like
openers when I'm like oh yeah I'm
celibate but like my friend over there
yeah she might be dead oh it's an opener
interesting it's like one of my because
I want to establish the friend zone
basically right away okay but also it
works out in my favor because if you
establish a friend zone right away you
might have friends that last years but
if you like kind of open up for
flirtation or this or that then they
like they'll want to [__] you and you
know if you do [__] which I'm celibate
but it's like you guys might not ever
talk again so it's like I'd rather
establish that do you do it that way
where it's like you established a friend
zone and then that way if they break
through then it's like oh cool like it
was real yeah yeah because every guy has
like oh my God I want to [__] you and
then it's like the three month Mark I've
noticed is every guy is like oh [__]
actually were you demystified yeah
they're like actually I don't like you
at all so [__] so you give them about
like three months of time to just hang
out and then yeah
at first because also
[Applause]
also and my dad at all because a lot of
girls a lot of girls Christian stripper
lovers
that's a website get the URL
Jennifer lovers how sick would it be if
you said that to a dude and he's all
he's all I'm celibate too oh my God
would that turn you off if he was like
I'm a virgin he's all I haven't had
section I haven't had sex in 40 years
honestly I think they're retired Fat
Boys they're like the best guys to [__]
because it's like retired yeah retired
[__] boys they're like oh actually this
doesn't feel like super meaningful
anymore but it was like cool because I'm
like a retired [__] girl it's like I
would [__] friend groups and be like I
don't know why you're mad
well it's a good Niche to find right
that's like you're equal though you know
well it's and then it would be really
funny because I would give them all
pointers like so his dick was bigger
than yours or your tips wow they would
ask they would ask like the first thing
they'd ask probably yeah they're like so
how else is dig versus mine and I was
like well this is what you did better so
you could rank the whole like they're
all taking notes okay um on a scale to
one to ten how was my cunnilingus stop
and they can all just Voltron together
they're all passing notes they're like
all right do this you're good at this
play
dude I get this they're all waiting in
the other room they're like Ryan it's
your turn all right let's go we all
stayed friends after which I think is
the coolest part because it's like there
was like no because we never had any
romantic interest in each other the
transparency yeah yeah just wanting to
[__] so it's like yo you're with that
girl all right I'm gonna [__] your
friend I'll hit you back was this in
Arizona yeah Arizona's a different
um
you're a celibate but are you like
looking to settle down one day oh a
thousand percent like that's I think I
mean with my career right now I don't
think I want to like jump in a
relationship or anything now but like I
would be looking to date someone before
I like I mean I don't know if I would
want to like have that exclusivity
before I [__] but it's like I do want to
find that connection and actually know
like all right you're someone I could
like see myself with I mean I don't want
kids or anything like that but
um also have you uh seen like when when
you tell dudes what you do do like would
they react different and be like oh
don't but also I try to get that out of
the way pretty soon so you just let them
know yeah it weeds out a lot of red
flags and I know there's a lot of only
fans girls thinking that they're worth
less because they do only fans and it
Narrows the dating pool and I'm like why
would you want a guy who judges only
fans girls anyways in my opinion it
opens up the dating pool to only the
good guys that's willing to date yeah
yeah like not all girls the only fans I
hear entrepreneur thank you but but you
know what I do I don't judge on the
sexual nature of it I judge on how
successful they are on it right because
you can't just be like yeah I was like
you only make five bucks a month people
are bad at it too yeah because I'm like
if you're gonna [__] show [__] yeah
if you're gonna do all that stuff right
then I want you to be successful at it
yeah yeah you know we're gonna do it
yeah is there anybody currently at the
moment that has somewhat like you're
kind of like hey he this person might
have a chance
um okay there was and like he always
made jokes about [__] me and I always
he's like not forever
wait it would be like we would be like
in conversation oh I gotta Mount me bro
like I would say like my time I love
golden retriever energy and he would
like reply back with something like ha I
have golden retriever energy so does
that count me in kind of thing about
like but then I I finally was just like
okay we've had a lot of like jokes kind
of about the stuff I was like listen if
you're interested in getting to know me
and like taking me on dates and stuff
like that it can be different he's like
yeah we're in two different places and
I'm like that's what I thought but like
I just communicated it off the bat
because usually a guy knows within a day
or two of meeting you if he just wants
to [__] you if he wants to date you and
it was way past that time limit so he
just wanted to [__] no yeah okay but
like the communication helps a lot so
then I don't fall in love with someone
who only sees me as a [__]
yeah I fell in love with someone that I
saw them as a [__] oh the first 10
minutes the first 10 minutes of meeting
her
um took a shower we just boned and then
uh well in real life we were chatting so
maybe like just chatting for a long time
on Instagram made the connection feel
more real it's a good story though yeah
yeah you're also an anomaly but then
no but the the whole the whole
the whole I tell her this straight up
too I had girls lined up
you got a [__] tour I was because oh
this was in the UK so I'm like if I'm
going out there I better meet all of
dick wet yeah and it was so it was so
magical that I didn't want anybody else
and then she just stayed with me the
whole week and it ended up being like
you know yeah real thing and then
um I don't know for her too was it was
like you're I'm just I'm just gonna use
you for your body and I was like really
well [__] I'm just being used you know
you started
we both gave up on the whole
relationship thing up until that time
but I [__] first and then relationship
later so I'm completely different but
maybe it's just because you know I don't
I'm not on only fans so I don't have to
worry about do they like me for me or is
it the only fans thing you know what I
mean yeah well I don't think I mean guys
here's the thing I used to not care if
they were like dirt poor but then after
enough comments and enough me paying for
both of our dinners and all of our Ubers
and it's tough now I'm like chips away
at a woman yeah they at least need to be
able to like pay for their life that's a
good that's a good one yeah
yeah in most cases I I think females
want a guy that makes more right but in
your case that even shrinks the dating
points even more because there's not
going to make more like my dad makes a
lot of money and I think he's pretty
miserable so it's like I want someone
who is passionate about what they do but
a lot of people who are passionate about
what they do don't make a lot of money
and that's where REI worker yeah but
then it's like if you're making less
than 20K a year which is one of the guys
I was [__] wow I paid for he would
have me pick him up so he didn't have to
pay for gas I had to pick him up from
the airport didn't even [__] me after I
feel like a glass blower or something
yeah a photographer
and then his girlfriend after
I was never his girlfriend he actually
was [__] me met this girl started
dating her two days later but brought us
to the same party and was dancing with
both of us it was very [__] weird and
then well he's living life right he's
getting taken care of like you're in the
he's getting picked up by the airport
he's [__] all these beautiful worlds
good I'm like where is he losing he's
not even cute but I was and he's got
good looking
yeah yeah
over six foot you're a womanizer but
then the girl after me it was like she
messaged me she was like
um yeah he was trying not to pay for
rent even after we broke up he was
trying to sleep on my couch and I'm like
bombs bro this chat this kind of writes
out all the all these thoughts of like
people are like oh guys have to make a
[__] ton they have to be this they have
you just got to be tall that's it no but
in a good box six two man he made he
makes girls come girls come first that
was his mom so but he's not gonna pay
for nothing though huh but he's not
gonna pay for him no no no because bro
guys have to learn how to [__] they're
like finally a dude that could make me
come
[Music]
please